ich bin nicht so dick sie ambulant ich
gerade eine bar mizwa verwandte und da
habe ich eine großcousine hatte mit
streik und das schwierige wurzeln
[Musik]
so ist noch pushen
sometimes i say something gehört
[Musik]
die flugzeugführer morgen sagt
glücklicherweise flüge in tel aviv dass
man dann nachher einigermaßen pünktlich
im büro morgen aber das ist spannend
weil man das alles weitere woche noch
dann ist es schwierig aber ich habe das
nicht so schlimm
auch die logistik aber es hat mir hat
das ok
[Musik]
ja
was ich ja wie der mutige schweizer
cafés und drei unter par zu wandern ist
landwirt das muss mit der sprache besser
als wie man das eine projekt das der
andere part landessprachen
wie gesagt ich will da nicht die fried
hat dann wäre es vielleicht anders
jetzt hat sie mir mit einem deutsch da
muss ich mir einen vorwurf machen
das ist einzigartig glaubt dehoga und so
standen einfach machen